thank you very much
very much
thank you very much everybody have a
seat thank you
have a seat everybody thank you
thank you wow that is
that is the first time i've touched my
nipple in like over a year
i know
the cdc said i couldn't do it i don't
know why it has nothing to do with
coverage
right right they said it was creepy
that's what they said
and i've told you you can do it at home
but you say it's not the same
it's not the same i need strangers
watching
uh these aren't strangers
you know i will say something nice about
this you are my second crowd in uh
second life crowd in 15 months but i do
want to say you're the first one i've
respected
i'll be honest
those people last night were low lifes
uh
i'm just gonna tell you right now yeah
they sold good weed though
as you probably know our uh our last
show is next uh thursday
june 24th that's uh yeah last show yeah
seven shows left before we wrap up the
nightly format
and then i'm off to join cameo now
here's the plan
here's birthday wishes shot in my
bathroom
yes birthday
bar mitzvah hundred dollars let's say i
think i'm gonna go for 120
a pop but i will take less i will take a
lot less
and if anyone here wants one just let me
know and i'll
i'll take care of it no no you haven't
seen the bathroom it's really sad
uh this is very exciting it is so nice
to be out here again and let's give it
up again
i uh i mentioned this uh last night one
thing we're doing
uh these last two weeks is taking a look
at some of my favorite moments
from our time here at tbs tonight
i'd like to show you a remote segment
from 2012
when i visited the irish american
heritage center
in chicago and i uh
i went to chicago and uh i learned the
uh sacred irish art of step
dancing and uh yeah so
uh well anyway here's what happened
i'm here with maureen o'looney i'm going
to learn irish step dancing today good
days today well you're in the right spot
now i'll be honest with you i don't have
much of a backside no you don't well you
don't need that for dancing
so legs is the most particular thing you
do need a back side to keep the legs
from
attached toe to the back and this is
what holds it happening no you haven't
enough
i haven't you have enough you'll pass
okay okay i didn't realize you were
studying me that closely
yeah down there you keep your eyes up
i'm up here morning okay
just hey it's my business not yours yeah
um we are entering the irish gift shop
now here at the irish american heritage
center
the soda bread oh soda bread we have the
irish version of bread
and the scones not very good english
bacon ice cream
harrington's high rise oh bacon and
winston bread that's not as good as
other bread
irish soda bread yeah whole wheat bread
it's good for your system
it's good for your system that's what
they always say when you're eating
something that's not tasty
these are potatoes look at that yeah
potatoes
just in case you mistakenly pronounce it
potato
they correct you no it's a tasty
[Applause]
oh how much for this this piece of turf
from ireland
yeah watch this top penny for this
yeah that's a special bit of turkey it's
called black stone turkey oh you are
running the greatest scam
of all time maureen oh there's a pizza
for you are you sure this isn't irish
bread
no no this is kind of looks the same oh
my lord it tastes like
[Applause]
[Music]
irish chef sauce right there that's good
that's the irish chef right
there he looks irish check that guy out
that's an irishman
how is he the irish chef he's from
mongolia
look at this guy that's not a leprechaun
that's a burn victim look at this guy
extra boxes of tanto
title
[Music]
when the irish american heritage center
purchased this school the first thing
they did
was they ripped out the library and
installed
this bar this is kindergarten for third
grade
right over here there's a second bar
and there's this bar on the second floor
and don't forget this third floor bar
and just across the hall from the third
floor bar
this portable bar on wheels
in case you can't get up this can be
brought to you in any location
and i'm sorry i almost forgot the fourth
floor bar
count them up that is six bars
in one former elementary school
we're here for the great moment this is
where i conan and o'brien learn
the uh art of irish step dancing in
cartoons the irish jig is always
you know this is what i kind of think it
is i mean i don't know what this
do you know what i mean when i think of
a guy finding gold at the end of the
rainbow i always think they're like
yeah this is what it was like for me as
a boy in fourth grade
so the feet one foot goes this way the
other one tuck it in behind them
this goes back that way yeah yeah okay
knees in now there's lots of tearing and
bleeding back here now is that normal
yes okay my arm's squeezing my body
i'm standing very still and
now you have to hold that hold this and
move your legs
and then and then dance while doing this
yes just move your legs it's impossible
it can't be done
put your arms out if they just float up
can we give me heavy things to hold i
mean what can we do
now the first thing is a jump right
kick out then kick out then back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well i'm feeling pretty confident about
my step dancing i think it's time for a
real performance
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
kicked a beautiful little girl in the
face
for a while that was your thing that was
my thing yeah yeah from 2012 to 2014
that was i owned that